welcome to the video playing chess
master 640 640 and the Pantheon II yeah
funny opening let's see Queen a fire
it's a relatively best move we should be
five is entirely incorrect but tricky
and this is well not incorrect but
certainly not something that black needs
to be afraid of d for I mean I don't
really believe in heat xt5 I think white
must play very very cautiously with d3
around here white is already struggling
to equalize actually I've threaten 90
for him Bishop c4 this OS Queenie for
check and it surprised that he is a
thinking here this is some the absolute
main line here of this opening maybe
he's just experimenting with her with
the pond Sione and stumbled into it
we should be 5 si six and then
threatening 94 it's not not likely can
play anything here funny you know here
yeah that's just a six yeah do you take
taking on see successor it's just just
fantastic for black and what exactly is
you move besides taking night a three
maybe yeah I have this check check very
strange okay let's consider ed for maybe
Knight d2 is coming can also castle long
ed 492
Queenie samne what what thoughts that
don't understand anything here I Queenie
seven maybe can then take on d4 actually
94 Bishop d7
or queen g4 actually also possible the
very weird stuff h3 queen to e6 and 94
Bishop d7 I can take G to this was
actually my original intention
Wow yeah let's do it no it takes yeah at
the end of all of that I have a pawn
yeah I've one upon hooray hooray maybe
there was something better but I didn't
turn I didn't didn't find it if there
was anything better then the somewhat
weak Queen side here gives him some some
counter play of course
Jack 97 22 f five probably and Joe I
don't want to want to play c-5m this is
not great king bee 796
may I need to need to activate pieces
here yeah this wasn't the best way to
play quite quite obviously I really
should have some continuation giving me
a substantial advantage but I didn't
find it Matty I'm wondering what
actually look h1b should be 5f forms the
stripped maybe hmm it's not not going
for that at all I can put the knight on
d5 don't really know what the smooth is
doing what f5 maybe f5 to to cover g7
Islam
okay can get the rook active here it's
not doing that much though okay but ok
the check Kings it Willis Bishop before
and it should give the check and here my
tools
now maybe we should be higher tough but
this at least secures the the point for
the moment
94 I have Knight f6 actually okay it's
not happening yeah look the rook might
be misplaced my morning check must be
must be cautious here
kinsey to i have night before
I know I get the beep on it has no way
to protect the snow king see to maybe
Jack didn't do that maybe just run with
the King to see foil
can even play you for now getting to see
three with the night yeah check it here
now maybe I can can wind a pawn okay i
have c 7 protected check Oh didn't see
that one but nothing nothing terrible
happened really
check-check
check check check check check check
check white for figs and Colleen whoo
yeah this was much tougher than that it
should have been after the opening I
mean around here if we look at this I
cannot I cannot really believe any of
that there should be subject some win
here how is black winning I look the
ages of winning and I just I just had a
total brain block here yeah rook da
twins I mean this Bishop is essentially
trapped yeah and something like this is
it's just not not working at all why the
Sun widest lost him he has no move in
this position after looked yet I really
a young I thought that this this would
be good as well but this far less
convincing I can I can do something like
that here of course but this is not
really check leading to anything but
equal play check just equal i guess he
loses castling rights and is somewhat
uncoordinated but it's still equal and
here i mean okay this is a pawn but we
can play book h 2 g1 and win oops played
this in two seconds though I have no I
have absolutely no square I can go here
but then it just takes and I'm getting
and I'm getting totally clobbered here
oops why this would have been very very
annoying
after after this opening disaster on the
white side yeah it's a guess equal he
has quite some compensation yeah I just
play route yet this really would have
refuted the whole thing and here we are
yeah we had a complicated position with
some some some tricky play 95 seems
better yeah put analyze this further
here it is pretty pretty unclear now I
guess he has some some play but it's
probably not enough for the porn here
the scene two points but I really should
play rook yet I really remember that
this is not playable what he did but I
didn't I didn't think of rookie aid just
for the moment if we just briefly looked
the aid what happens if he attacks the
Queen yeah then i can take here right
it's just just a piece yeah I was stupid
alright thanks for watching